Adam Crowell lives by that rule still he
joins us tonight Adam thank you so much
for coming on how do you how do you do
how do you do comedy in A Moment Like
This you still do stand up
yes I was on a stage at The Improv in
Hollywood last night and I was on a
stage with another comedian and I
started getting into some subject matter
and I could see in his eyes like don't
go there we don't want to get into
trouble and that's a very troubling
notion comedians second guessing
themselves worried about getting into
trouble and also this notion of these
idiots saying because a comedian says
something people are going to go do it
as if you did whatever George Carlin was
talking about in the 70s or Mort Saul or
Richard Pryor you know it's even like
when they're accusing Trump of telling
people to inject bleach okay he's
dangerous because he told people to
inject bleach how many Americans
injected bleach this is the president of
the United States and this is their
excuse for canceling everyone because
they know people don't listen to Dave
Chappelle or Trump saying to and inject
bleach it's just an excuse for them to
have dominion over you
it may be however that they're on to at
least one point the one thing that
average people might copy from a
comedian is the willingness to mock the
people in charge maybe that's what they
fear they don't want to be mocked
yeah and there's a definite truth in
comedy that cuts right to the core and
they know if they lose and can't silence
that Community there's going to be
issues remember when Jon Stewart was on
Stephen Colbert's show several months
ago and he was like hello Wuhan lab leak
there's a virology lab up the street
don't you think a watch Colbert's
reaction to that he was like oh my God
one of our own has crossed the line but
it's not crossing the line it's a
comedian being funny and making
observations that are patently true
so how have you I've always wondered I
don't know if I ever asked you how have
you continued to act like it's 1986 when
it's not why doesn't it affect you
well this is going to sound self-serving
but you'll see it almost everywhere you
have to be good if you're good you say
what you want Dave Chappelle is good Jon
Stewart is good they say what they want
most people live in the middle if you're
a journalist and you have any kind of
Integrity you quit your job at the New
York Times and you go to sub stack those
are the good ones but most people aren't
good most people are in the middle and
when you're in the middle whether you
work for a big Corporation or the New
York Times or Netflix you need to keep
your job most Americans want to keep
their job over about anything else
they're not good enough and they don't
feel they're good enough to say whatever
they want and do whatever they want
well that's a real I mean that's a
really good point I wonder though when
all of this ends won't a lot of
comedians be ashamed that they went
along with speech codes which are
antithetical to Comedy and free thinking
comedians eat count chocula at four in
the morning in a bathrobe in their
living room every night they do not feel
shame they they don't have the shame
gears that the rest of uh
America is constrained by so no they
don't normally feel shame they eat
edibles stay up all night and make fart
jokes so there are hard demographic to
shame but my feeling is is if you're a
comedian you got in it to say what you
wanted to say and if you're curtailing
that in any way especially because some
woke a-holes are going after you then
you're a coward and you've given in to
the Mob and you become a comedian to
push back against the man and the man is
not Rhonda santis the man is the woke
mob if you're a comedian
well that's exactly right have you do
you worry that venues or your perform
could be shut down
um no but it doesn't mean it can't
happen I don't have a choice I'm a
comedian I have to say what I'm thinking
some people like it some people won't
like it but the second that process ends
I gotta go back to carpentry
still living like it's a free country
Adam Carolla joins us tonight Adam thank
you so much
thanks Tucker subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight